This first answer doesn't really help. Size doesn't matter, it's transparency
that's causing the problem. The second answer works. The blue object is further
from the eye than the red one, so will be drawn first. However, for more
complicated scenes, it's a bit of overkill and inefficient to boot. The sorting
order of a set of opaque objects doesn't affect the final result on the screen,
that's the z buffer's job to sort out. Drawing a pick objects in a back to front
order is not efficient, as fragments will be processed by the fragment shader,
then covered up by the next closest object. The third answer is not
particularity meaningful, and won't solve anything. The blue object essentially
already has an alpha, it's equal to one meaning fully opaque. Even with blending
on, an opaque object will still act like an opaque object. This solution does
not fix the problem that the blue object does not being rendered early enough.
The fourth answer works for this case, where there is only one transparent
object. First all the opaque objects are drawn, there's only one, it is then
guaranteed that the transparent object will be able to blend with the opaque
objects as needed.